Whatever the fuck they did with Jordan
Peterson, they created a god damn monster.
Oh yeah, you guys fucked up. What?
You guys created a multimillionaire
whose worldwide famous and there's a huge
bestseller. He was just talking to the
Swedish politicians on TV the other day,
so you know, watch out.
This fucked up with him.
Boy did they fuck up and Dave
was just texting me a friend.
Reuben was just texting me
pictures that all full. It's crazy.
And that energy and that place is crazy.
He's selling out 5,000 seat theaters is
a rock star. It's a fucking rock star.
He's an intellectual rock
rockstar. It's hilarious. Good
for him. Yeah. I mean look,
a lot of other guys are doing it to
Sam Harris is doing that now as well.
They do in these gigantic huge speeches.
It's like good for him though. Fine.
We'll absolutely good for him.
But
what I'm excited about is how many people
are interested in the debate of ideas
and that this is not happening
on the college campuses,
but a lot of these people
that have graduated have
graduated from college or you
know, or in the working world, they're
very fascinated by this. It's real.
It's what you were saying, it's been
suppressed for long enough now. You know,
Jordan Peterson, what was
his thing? He was like,
you're not going to tell me
the words I can use, right.
When there's 78 different
words for genders,
I can safely say you're fucking crazy.
It's like this desperation to try to
find a unique identity that you can
consider it to be super special or
whatever. It's totally, but it's,
and you want to see you even
crazier as you go into the,
like you go on these blogs and I think
they're mostly on Tumblr or something and
it violates my rule.
Never use tumbler. Um,
where they talk about the different
sexual sexuality identities,
like different kinds of, you know,
I'm interested in this kind of person,
but not this kind of person
under these circumstances.
But not under those that has like some,
you know,
18 syllable academic word for it now.
And there's people whose whole,
I don't think their academics,
I think they're activists geeks on Tumblr,
but they come up with these crazy
descriptions and there's like hundreds of
sexual orientations. Yeah. It's
just people wanting to be different,
I think sounded be special and
they're not good at anything.